vas-y actualités internationales vous me
dit merzelinski rejette les accusations
russes de bonsaal et il demande une
réponse dure du côté des Occidentaux la
Russie accuse l'Ukraine depuis hier
d'être entré dans une phase finale de
fabrication d'une bombe sale Paris
Londres et Washington ont fustigé une
telle accusation dans une déclaration
conjointe d'ailleurs on retrouve et bien
notre correspondant à Kiev Gulliver crag
Gulliver bonsoir ces déclarations ont
lieu alors qu'une partie de Kiev est
toujours dans le noir aujourd'hui
et dans cette région d'Ukraine il y a
des interruptions d'électricité plus ou
moins programmées pour faciliter les
réparations après les fractes ces
derniers jours je dis programmer mais en
fait des consommateurs se plaignent que
les coupures de courant n'ont pas
vraiment toujours lieu selon le
programme la compagnie d'électricité a
promis de faire mieux dans les jours qui
viennent pour adhérer à son propre
programme d'interruption de courant il y
a une grande partie de coudeker qui est
dans le noir en ce moment pas mon
quartier vous voyez derrière moi et
encore un petit peu d'éclairage dans les
rues mais à d'autres quartiers il y a
même pas cela et puis il y a des régions
dans l'ouest du pays où le courant a été
coupé de manière absolument pas
programmée au moment même des frappes de
samedi ce sont les régions de merlinski
et de vos lignes dans le
nord-ouesty aujourd'hui ils ont
finalement annoncé avoir pu rétablir le
courant pour tous les foyers mais vont
passer maintenant à la phase
d'interruption programmée dont le volume
dont le nord-ouest il y a encore
certaines localités qui n'ont toujours
pas depuis samedi le courant
la contre-offensive ukrainienne en tout
cas dans le Sud aux alentours de Kerson
continue
Gulliver qu'est-ce qui se passe
véritablement en ce moment dans le sud
alors il reste assez difficile de savoir
puisque l'Ukraine maintient une sorte de
placard en terme d'information j'ai
parlé ce soir à une connaissance qui est
combattant en fait dans cette région et
je lui ai demandé s'il pouvait me dire
vraiment de la manière la plus générale
qui soit est-ce qu'elle était beau de
l'offensive se maintient ou est-ce que
cela ralentit il a dit non désolé je
peux vraiment rien vous dire mais
cela étant dit les militaires ukrainiens
ont annoncé aujourd'hui avoir repris le
contrôle depuis le début de cette
contre-offensive de 90 communes dans la
région de Herson est-ce qu'ils sont près
de la capitale régionale difficile à
dire mais ce qui était intéressant
aujourd'hui c'est que le chef des
renseignement militaire
ukrainien qui reloada a dit que il
voyait que les Russes envoyaient des
renforts à Herson et se préparer à des
combats de rue dans la ville même ceux
qui contraste un peu avec ceux qui
avaient dit d'autres officielles
ukrainiens et des experts militaires qui
soupçonnaient les Russes ont fait de se
retirer en cachette de Herson sous
couverture de leurs évacuations de civil
merci beaucoup Gulliver crack en direct
de Kiev